[Musique]
oh alors pouvons-nous arrêter,
alors pouvons-nous arrêter,
il est temps d'arrêter, il est
grand temps que vous commenciez,
ils espèrent que ça se passe comme il est
censé se passer, il y a de la peur en eux tous
mais ils
ne peuvent pas laisser cela montrer qu'ils sont sous-préparés
mais pas
[Musique]
il est temps
nous pouvons être d'accord alors pouvons-nous arrêter
[Musique]
alors fermez toutes les portes et commençons
le spectacle les sorties sont clairement moquées
mais vous devez savoir que les offres sont là
alors ne montrons pas de dédain  le bureau est
ici et là
un peu
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs, s'il vous plaît, taisez-vous et asseyez-vous,
les armes de nos idées
se lèvent paresseusement, mais où est la scène que vous vous
demandez est-ce à l'
extérieur
ou est-ce à l'
extérieur à l'intérieur à l'extérieur à
l'intérieur
alors pouvons-nous arrêter
alors bébé commence
c'est  il est temps d'arrêter
[Musique]
il est temps de commencer
mon temps
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pouvons-nous maintenant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous